and in this town most people want to be
able to place you as doing something
they want to Pigeon hold you in that so
one I did seven years of Malcolm in the
Middle and it was great and I thought
how could I do something different at
this moment same year I got a notice
that said well you did a an episode of
X-Files and the writer of that episode
Vince Gilligan would like to see you
about this show called Breaking Bad and
I read it and it was just incredible and
what Vince said he wanted to do at the
outset is he wanted to change the main
character throughout the course of the
series which has never been done in
series television if you look at Archie
Bunker Tony Soprano or whomever they
react to different stimulus but they are
the same person whereas Walter White was
going to change from a good honest guy
to becoming a killer as as Vince
Gilligan often says he said I just want
to see if I can change a guy from Mr
Chips to Scarface they're not going to
let me I know they're just not going to
let me do it